foreign
[Music]
first appeared on Earth around 400
million years ago long before dinosaurs
walked the Earth
they were extraordinarily abundant
with over 30 000 different species
of all shapes and sizes
one do we really know about the way they
lived
in terms of lifestyles of ammonites
their morphology is so diverse
that their range of Lifestyles would
have been really diverse
today millions of fossilized ammonite
shells are found all over the world
but they tell us frustratingly little
about the animal that lived inside
the greatest problem that we have is
there are only a small number of fossils
that do actually preserve the soft parts
of ammonites and they never really give
us the exact information that we would
like
so how do we know anything about these
mysterious animals
we're quite lucky in the ammonites
belong to the large group of mollusks
called the cephalopods
these include the modern day Nautilus
and it provides crucial evidence about
what ammonites were like
Nautilus today has a chambered shell
and the animal itself lives in the very
last chamber
the morphology of ammonite shelves is
almost identical
we now believe like Nautilus ammonites
had tentacles
well-developed eyes
and use the chambers inside their shells
for stability in the water
Nautilus today as ammonites would have
done control their buoyancy just like as
a marine by emptying the chambers of
water to be able to float
and refilling them to be able to sink
modern cephalopod shows us how ammonites
swam
an octopus propels Itself by squirting
water through a tube called a siphon
all cephalopods have siphons and it's
likely some ammonites use theirs to swim
at great speed
some of them with fast-moving Predators
adapted for Fairly rapid movement but
others appear to have been slow swimmers
feeding on plankton
our nights were extraordinarily
successful animals that existed twice as
long as the dinosaurs
so why did they go extinct
[Music]
most ammonites went extinct about 66
million years ago about the same time as
the dinosaurs went extinct
an asteroid six miles wide struck the
Earth causing major impacts to many
ecosystems including the shallow Seas
ammonites did have one critical weakness
compared to other cephalopods
they appear to have been constrained to
laying their eggs in Fairly shallow
water
this put the young at the mercy of the
catastrophic changes to the food chain
after the asteroid impact
[Music]
photosynthesis wouldn't have been able
to occur so much in the planktonic plant
life in the oceans and that would have
had a greater impact on the shallow
oceans and the shallow oceans were where
the ammonites were living
it spelled the end to 300 million years
of ammonite evolution
but they left behind a fascinating
Legacy
and a crucial insight into life in the
prehistoric scenes
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign